flying high take a look at these shots
eight news now digital reporter Duncan
Phoenix got an inside peek at Red Flag
drills as they continue at Nellis Air
Force Base yesterday's training
simulated combat against Chinese Jets
and air defenses British and Australian
forces are also taking part
so this mission is to simulate a
XO our role will be to support the force
to effectively
proceed into the area that's been
occupied and to undertake targeting of
key assets to allow us to degrade the
enemy's capabilities
the red flag drills in tomorrow coming
up at 4 30 hear more from the U.S
officials as they say these drills are
not tied to the suspected Chinese spy
balloon that was shot down by a fighter
jet